هيا من رجال المقاومه الاسلاميه في سوريا
الى المقاومه الشريف عصام الدردور
[موسيقى]
حلو اخر رساله وربي ينصر المقاومه كلها في
هذا في وربي
ثبتني الناس الكل ان شاء الله
والله العظيم اخي احساس يعني جميل وغير
عادي وانا اسمع اي رساله
[موسيقى]
لا الدوله اعطتني حاجه لا شافت لي خدمه
انا
جارت علي
[موسيقى]
هل وجدتم اي ايادي للدوله لاجهزه امنيه في
هذا الهجوم هجوم بردو ويستعين مع مرور
الوقت نكتشف ان ذلك كان انعداما بشكل واضح
ولكن في الواقع يمكن ان يكون مرتبطا ايضا
بشيء قد تم التخطيط له مسبقا من قبل جهه
خفيه في الدوله التونسيه حينها ليس لدي
دليل دامغ لاثبات ذلك لكن في الحقيقه هذا
امر يمكننا التفكير فيه
[موسيقى]
نعم النمر متواجد في تونس وبحريه يتحرك
بحريه تامه وبعد الحكم ببراءه هؤلاء يعني
واليقين بان ما حصل كان مسرحيه وسقوط قتلى
وسقوط شهداء من الحرس الوطني الى يومنا
هذا لازال جميع الالارعين في هذه الجريمه
كغيرها من الجرائم